I have it enlarged heart. How do I reduce the size naturally? Right now, my doctor's had me on blood pressure meds.
Well, typically you won't go on blood pressure meds just because you have it in a large heart. You'd go on blood pressure meds because you either have high blood pressure
or you have irregular beats. So if you have a irregular irregularity of your heart due to an enlarged heart, then you might be a beta blockers type of which is a blood pressure med, but that's typically what you'd use if you had an enlarged heart.
If you have a high blood pressure, without anything else, then typically you'll go on like an ACE2 inhibitor which would be like a mesinoperm or something like that.
Can you reduce your enlarged heart naturally? No, you can't reduce your enlarged heart naturally.
Having an enlarged heart is common. It's common with athletes. I have an enlarged heart because I ran track across country at high school probably.
The danger of an enlarged heart is that as your heart is growing and the muscle tissue is expanding, it can cause your valves to maybe not shut as thoroughly.
Then you can get valveular issues where you get some regurgitation in the ventricles. That is a possibility. Also, with an enlarged heart, you can get some issues with the cytokine atrial node and you can get issues with irregular beats.
None of those are really dangerous except the valveular issue if you're end up getting valveular infections.
Typically, treating with using garlic in your diet, unless you have an autoimmune disease. If you don't have an autoimmune disease using garlic on a regular basis, it's probably the best thing for any infections.
On the valves and the infections in the blood system in general, garlic is one of the best solutions for that.
But no, there isn't really anything from a natural perspective for that. If a person has irregularities or tachycardia issues, also you want to look at vitamin D from a tachycardia perspective.
Over the years, I've had patients that had different times where they go into a ventricular tachycardia and it was from a vitamin D deficiency.
I had one patient once, this was years ago, whose mother was in thericular tachycardia. They were going to use the shock pads under which they don't like to do on anybody that is alive because that could kill them or anybody that is awake because they could be very dangerous.
All she did is give her mom a 20,000 I use a vitamin D and it called your heart out. She didn't have to have it without a virus.
So that could be an issue. So getting your vitamin D levels checked in your blood would be wise. We've had people get the right of the D levels checked in, it's like 15.
So a person even taking vitamin D can have low vitamin D levels because you could have vitamin D receptor defects on your genes so you don't absorb vitamin D very well, you know, utilize it very well if you need to take a lot more than what you're taking.
So those are some things to consider for that.